منذ لحظات فقط الليلة، قال إيلون ماسك في
مقابلة مع أندرو روس سورين في
قمة كتاب الصفقات في نيويورك تايمز
هذا للمعلنين الذين تركوا X بسبب
تأييده للمحتوى المعادي للسامية
إذا كان شخص ما سيحاول
ابتزازي بالإعلان،
يبتزني  المال يذهب
بنفسك ولكن اذهب
بنفسك هو هذا
الوضوح وآمل أن
يكون الأمر واضحًا تمامًا الآن
دانا هول بلومبرج كبير المراسلين الذي
يغطي إيلون ماسك، لذلك ذكرت دانا نيويورك
تايمز أن هذا المنشور المعادي للسامية
قد يكلف X ما يصل إلى 75
مليون دولار  في إيرادات الإعلانات المفقودة هذا العام،
يحذر " ماسك " من أن
مقاطعة الإعلانات يمكن أن تقتل
الشركة، وهو ليس سعيدًا بها، ومن
الرائع بالنسبة له أن يقول ذلك
بالطبع بناءً على سبب
حدوث المقاطعة، نعم أعني أنني أعتقد أن ما
رأيته الليلة في The Dealbook  لقد كانت القمة بمثابة
المسك الأصيل، أعني أنه غاضب من
ذلك لكنه لن يغير لهجته
ولن يغير الطريقة التي
يعمل بها لمجرد أن المعلنين
يغادرون المنصة وأنت تعلم أن
إسقاط قنابل F في قمة كبيرة مثل
دفتر الصفقات أمر غير معتاد  بالنسبة لمدير تنفيذي ولكن كما
نعلم جميعًا الآن، فإن إيلون ماسك ليس
مديرًا تنفيذيًا نموذجيًا بأي حال من الأحوال،
أه لا بالتأكيد ليس هذا
صحيحًا، كما تعلم أنه تحدث أيضًا
عن رحلته الأخيرة إلى إسرائيل
قائلًا إنه تم التخطيط لها قبل  تداعيات
أنها لم تكن جولة اعتذار، فقد
اعتذر بالفعل على الرغم من أن صحيفة The Post قالت
إنه من بين كل الأشياء التي كتبها على X،
كان الأمر الأكثر حماقة الذي
قاله على المنصة على الإطلاق، حيث كان معجبًا
بتسليم مسدس محشو لأولئك الذين
أكرهني ويمكن القول لأولئك الذين يعادون
السامية ويقولون إنه
آسف تمامًا لم تكن نيته أم أن هذا
مجرد محاولة لحفظ ماء الوجه أم أن هذا
حقيقي بالفعل كما تعلم أعتقد أنه مزيج
من الاثنين أعني أننا أخيرًا  احصل على هذا النوع
من شبه الاعتذار بعد مرور أسبوعين على
المنشور الأولي الذي لا يزال موجودًا على
المنصة، ولم يتم حذفه، وأنت تعلم
أنني أعتقد أن " ماسك " ليس دائمًا
الشخص الأكثر ذكاءً عاطفيًا، كما أنه ليس دائمًا أفضل قارئ
على الإطلاق.  يميل إلى إطلاق النار
من الورك وقول أشياء بدون
مرشح ويمكن أن يأتي ذلك بنتائج عكسية وهو ما
رأيناه طوال حياته المهنية،
لكنه كما تعلم كان هذا هو أقرب
ما رأيناه يعبر عن
الندم  والندم على الطريقة التي
فُسرت بها كلماته، أعني أنك تعلم أن
بعض النصائح قد تكون عدم التغريد أو
عدم النشر، لكن من الواضح أنه مالك
المنصة وهذا من
صلاحياته، ولا أعلم ما إذا كان هذا الشخص
سينجح في ذلك  خاصة
بسبب ما رأيناه بالأمس وهو
يدعم
نظرية المؤامرة التي تم فضحها منذ فترة طويلة ولكن
يدعم ذلك أيضًا، هناك
الكثير من هذه اللحظات عندما تجمعها
جميعًا، أعني أنها تثير سؤالاً
هو ما هو مستقبل X في  هذه النقطة
خاصة مع قيام المعلنين
بالأرقام التي
نراها، أعتقد أن Musk يحاول حقًا
التركيز على نموذج الاشتراك
حيث يريد إنشاء الأشخاص الذين
تعرفهم يريدون أن يكونوا على X للدفع مقابل
مستويات مختلفة من الوصول وهو
لا يريد أن يكون مدينًا للمعلنين
، وهذا نوع من
المفارقة الجامحة هنا هي أنك تعلم أن ماسك خلق
تسلا هذه القوة المذهلة في
صناعة السيارات دون الاعتماد على
الإعلان على الإطلاق، ثم اشترى
شركة التواصل الاجتماعي هذه
يعتمد بشكل كبير على الإعلانات
وأعتقد أن هذا نوع من الدائرة التي
لا يمكنه تربيعها، نعم أه استمع، هناك
الكثير هناك وأنا سعيد لأنك
تشاهدها باهتمام شديد لأنه
يمكنك ترجمة الكثير منها من أجل  لي
دانال شكرا لوجودك معنا
الليلة